y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es una representación
de escribir soy diseñador sin productor
de eventos soy un poco esto de este
hablar con la persona es público es el
tiempo que algún ejercicio
trabajo relacionada con el público que
rápidamente a los 5 10 15 cosas
pero mucha gente encuestas
influidas que conecta con ellas
un dibujo
con la particularidad de poder hacer que
el chat una simulación soporta dibujando
el papel y en menos de 40 segundos
pedido por el personal
algo que me pase coloque el gran evento
lo siento desde lo que voy a dibujar es
que por un ratito un poco pesada
y los ojos
dominante en el ojo por un ratito te
conectas con leche de esa persona
ahora estoy pensando
yo tengo personas que he dibujado
innumerable cantidad de cómics
mientras terminamos la carta
son hijos de personal
en forma de libro que se usa mucho ahora
tiene que ver
con un libro que viene en una caja que
tiene hojas
tecnológicamente con un celular pueden
venir con links en alguna página 2
lo va a encontrar en la pc los chicos lo
va a encontrar la cocina si un objeto
para adulto lo va a encontrar capas en
el modular o en el comedor dinerito
decimos como lector
tenés que de una u otra manera
intelectual con el segundo muchos que
sean personas que puedan hallar el
jarama genial o jaguar tiene un costo
alto de hacerlo por estas
particularidades lo conseguí en
librerías y en los sobres conseguir y
jugueterías
qué me pasó cuando dije voy a hacer
crisis
fíjense comience la charla diciendo no
tener cinco cosas que no te gustan nos
puede contar lo que nos gusta cuando el
libro el nombre de la gente
en el momento no sabemos hacer todos es
decir si es que se está usando
expresiones palabras
super similar
se llama financiamiento colectivo
mujeres
deben guardar el círculo rojo por tales
diferencias este colectivo porque lo
personal de cambio sería una locura es
muy simple de arte y ciencia mente
colectivo les voy a dar un ejemplo yo
les estaba contando de un objeto poner
un monto económico está va a ser lo
vamos a decir cinco partidos cinco años
si queréis viajar por el mundo son
periodistas deportistas necesita hacer
un viaje
vamos a hacer 50 15 viaje de cuenta
a 20
el colectivo no importa si necesitas un
chico necesita un monto sideral distinto
la base exacta mentira
primer punto de la base de
financiamiento es el tiempo las campas y
financiamiento de campaña política
larga tienen un crecimiento van llegando
y la gente quiere saber si logra este no
lograr que conseguir la trata el tiempo
en el campaña evidencia este colectivo
suele ser de 40 días
porque nos dijo que con el tiempo porque
no dos o tres meses porque con esto de
la zona información nos pasa que se nos
va a tener
cinco días
menos de 60 segundos porque el tiempo
es práctico
y conciso
bien en una caja color interactivo de
los segundos
no te olvides que no estaba siendo la
publicidad en contacto por favor si se
suman al proyecto si se suman en mis
sueños me acompaña
a ese punto
el soporte digital que el soporte
digital
a la gente
se ha generado para contener el aluvión
y ayudas de gente que se empieza a sumar
a esta economía colaborativo
a ayudar
a comprar un bono de ayuda
cuarto punto y en uno de los más claves
de financiamiento
creo que hoy lo conocimos todo
y hasta aquí
entonces
contando que tu viaje
porque estamos en la era de la
tecnología de amigos y familia
ni hablar si se suman
sumando palitos pero si no se descuenta
que haga el pico cerca del más conocido
porque vos no sabés quién está atrás de
tus límites de contacto
qué quiere decir terminar el
financiamiento y lo más clave que parece
en realidad recompensa
[Música]
algo que tenga mucho
en esta idea
yo armé un plan de recompensas artes
recompensas
por 29
en ese momento un gran ejercicio para
saquear las recompensas por siglos
porque yo nunca pensé en poner la imagen
de viaje ps en recompensa
para
necesitaban 5 puntos
en 30 días
dinero que financia este colectivo yo
digo no lo conocimos no porque no se usa
porque nos cuenta creer en que la gente
confía en que la gente se suma
tiene que ver con esto
sólo un poco de
en el alma
por qué
es un choque
así
en el alma
tiene que ver
con esto
con el objeto donde bordado
[Aplausos]